ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen minecraft welt
meine lieben freunde direkt zu beginn
der heutigen episode möchte ich mich
riesig für euren support der letzten
episode bedanken das hat mich sehr
gefreut waren in den deutschen youtube
trends und jetzt wieder mega viele tipps
gegeben wie zb der hier also daran halte
ich mich wirklich fest was ihm
allerdings auch geschrieben wurde war
dass das hier kein kartentisch ist im
sinne von hey da kann man jetzt
irgendwie uno gegeneinander spielen oder
keine ahnung was sondern das ist für
richtige landkarten und da ich die nicht
habe ist das dann auch relativ egal was
mir auch geschrieben wurde war luca
bitte nimm diese heuballen mit die kann
man wohl ganz easy einfach zum brot
weiter verkraften und es ist eine
platzsparende an ich bin diese kleinen
so lustig ne weizen können wir
einerseits zum traden benutzen
andererseits allerdings auch für brot
damit wir ganz ein
[Musik]
wright ist erneut offen
ich würde sagen den apparat nehmen wir
auch mal mit es tut mir leid ich weiß ja
nicht was mir ein räucherofen bringen
soll allerdings also die sachen habe ich
mir jetzt einfach mal alles inventar
gepackt das boot ist natürlich mit das
allerwichtigste und dann würde ich jetzt
auch sagen dass schon mittag angebrochen
ist dass wir das dorf jetzt mal
verlassen werden
danke ich weiß ich habe euch auch echt
lieben gelernt und zwar wurde mir auch
noch unten in die kommentare geschrieben
das in meinem dorf wohl meine diamanten
geklaut wurden
ich weiß nicht ob ich dumm bin oder
[Musik]
der chef ein paar sekunden später
ich weiß nicht was mit diesem bienen los
ist ich weiß nämlich dass dinge abbauen
kann ich will sie nicht schlagen weil in
real life weiß ich dass wenn man da rein
fast dass das echt weh tut das kann ich
bezeugen weil ich erst mal damals auch
wir fahren allerdings weg von dem
komischen bienen dorf stall bienen
gehege wie heißt dieses ding in haus
hall zwiener jetzt wird es allerdings
auch ziemlich schnell dunkel gerade von
daher ganz schnurstracks ins stift damit
wieder einen auf der insel damit die ich
vorhin bereits gesagt wurde mir
geschrieben dass meine diamanten aus dem
dorf hier wohl geklaut wurden ich weiß
jetzt nicht ob das wirklich geschehen
kann dass da irgendwie die dorfbewohner
sich denken 'mensch tallinn diamanten in
der kiste die könig märz mal wenn das
wirklich der fall sein sollte dann bin
ich ja der größte coup im kompletten
minecraft universum ihr könnt immer
gerne in die kommentare schreiben
der kommentar ich gemeint war oder ob
dir irgendwie ich wieder fahrrad wurde
aber die sind halt keine diamanten mehr
drin ich weiß aber auch nicht ob da
wirklich jemals welche drin waren ich
muss jetzt auf jeden fall nochmal den
bibliotheken backofen ich weiß nicht wer
das von denen hier war das sind gerber
keine ahnung was ihm aber nicht wegen
die lederjacken oder so ist das ist der
bibliothek warburg und er
lehrling es geht nicht ich will bücher
haben also normale nicht verzauberte
weil ich brauche die normalen kannst du
dir vielleicht geben
ich habe eine idee man da nicht in frage
und zwar die mich jetzt einfach sein
lesepult weg und mache jetzt was ich in
den kommentaren gelesen habe werde
nämlich einfach mein boot
das schafft ich nehme jetzt einfach mal
ein boot und setzt das mal hier hin und
muss jetzt halt irgendwie in die
videotheken warum sie dafür muss ich
erst mal so einen kleinen weg bauen mit
dem wir dann nach draußen
[Musik]
nein nein
brookes challenge hoffentlich keine
zombies stelle hochschulmeister er ist
nie ganz weg
da ist der schamlos rein da den borat
was ich sagen wollte war dass wir auf
jeden fall ich halt immer ganz kurz eben
hier vorne an wir müssen hier ein paar
sumpf blätter mitnehmen ein ich habe
keine ich habe keine schere dabei ich
will eigentlich sumpf letter mitnehmen
weil mir die kommentare geschrieben
wurde dass man mit sumpf blättern
ziemlich schönen weg zu meiner
zauberinsel bauen kann und dass man
nicht eine ganz geile idee also mit
diesem see rosenblättern allerdings habe
ich keine schere dabei von daher ist
jetzt der plan sich diese madame hier
meiner insel bringe schlafe wieder
zurück wo die seerosenblätter hat und
weil ich wieder zurück und eigentlich
hab ich nen fetten plant wort aber das
wissen ich bin spieler bei einer stunde
einen tag später der erste dorfbewohner
auf meiner insel meine damen und herren
herzlich willkommen es geht doch
eigentlich oder mal hoch ich weiß nicht
warum ich da gerade so internet bin aber
ich will die ganze zeit verfolge gucken
was mr reitet eine schildkröte sondern
ist dass das wurden allerdings auch und
in die kommentare geschrieben und zwar
können wir unsere schildkröten wohl
miteinander paaren wenn wir dieses
seegras hier abbauen von einer nämlich
jetzt einfach mal ganz viel seegras hier
unten und das geile daran ist und ich
habe diese schildkröte ehrlich gesagt
nie so richtig lieben gelernt weil die
einfach nur im weg rum standen aber das
coole an den schildkröten ist wirklich
dass man sagt das ist das ist eine menge
seegras ihr seht auf jeden fall schon
dass die schildkröte mega auf das
seegras abfährt und wir können jetzt
einfach mal mit der schildkröte rüber zu
den anderen gehen und rechtsklick
draufmachen und zack und hier auch
rechtsklick und zack weil wir haben ein
paar mehrere und jetzt fahren die sich
mit der mit einer nah und ich hab weiß
nicht wie das funktioniert hier vorne
als erfahrung ich glaube die kriegen
jetzt baby schildkröten
das ist allerdings nicht wurde jetzt und
jetzt sind nur wenige minuten später für
mich zudem erwarten sind
j
[Musik]
wie viel spaß hat er sich aus was
passiert da jetzt noch mal oder was da
so an 412 was machst du denn da unten
12345 wir haben zwölf schildkröte naja
eigentlich hatten wir hier vorne ja auch
noch schildkröten diesen irgendwie
abgehoben als jetzt nicht aus der hand
hat um 1 auf einer sind hier usain bolt
in lecce in grün oder was und das ganze
noch ein bisschen zusätzlich noch ein
bisschen auseinander gerupft aus auf der
andern seite wo ich das noch machen sagt
ein bisschen schöner aus ist schon
wieder nacht und dann bewege ich mich
mal ins bettchen meine lieben freunde
ich bin gespannt was der winter uns da
ich noch sagen wird weil mit dem haben
ja noch gar nicht so richtig interagiert
allerdings werde ich jetzt mal reisen
nehmen und meine rüstung so ein bisschen
wieder auf den neuesten stand bringen
zusammen
er soll einen neuen hut und neue stiefel
habe ich mir jetzt mal kurz gemacht die
eisenbahn packe ich auch noch ein
bisschen was wir uns endlich wahr machen
könnten
keine ahnung was bringt ich stelle ihn
allerdings einfach mal hier vorne drauf
da steht doch nicht so komplett im raum
herum
mir wurde geschrieben dass ich einfach
meinen namen stellt nehmen kann und das
jetzt hier reinpacken kann und wer nicht
das namensschild beispielsweise viele
verdammt verschrieben
für den film lebt die nicht dumm peter
philipp r
so und jetzt haben wir das ding muss ich
damit einfach rechtsklick auf den delfin
machen oder wie funktioniert das werden
wir gleich heraus wenn meine lieben
freunde denn wir bewegen uns ja auf
jeden fall nochmal zum sumpfgebiet
hinten wo wird die seerosenblätter holen
müssen für den weg zu unserer kleinen
zauberinsel bevor das quartal
du nervst ein bisschen am können die
kartoffel der gold hat auch für mich ja
zu verfolgen
ich nehme mal ganz kurz die sachen hier
du bist schon fett wie ein arsch und da
sind wir auch schon hier bei unserem
kleinen sumpf biom angekommen nehmen ist
aber die schere und nehmen hier und zum
part seerosenblätter mit die sind ganz
geil weil ich auch später natürlich in
den neckar gehen will dafür brauchen wir
einen portal michaela zugesprungen unter
wasser habe ich dann allerdings
folgendes entdeckt club heißt dahin ich
weiß nicht wo er hin schwimmt oder ob er
wieder mit irgendwelchen items hintenrum
spielt aber ich habe extra roden lachs
mitgenommen und ich habe das
namensschild mitgenommen ich weiß
allerdings nicht wie ich denn hier
zählen kann ich versuche mir einfach zu
ihm rüber zu schwimmen da hinten
deutlich schneller als ich immer da ist
mein gott es tut er hier von lachs und
hier clipper dass nach dem stellt dass
sein schritt flipper spielt okay er
spielt mit den see rosenblättern rum
richtig so freuen sich andere über
abitur noch unter wasser habe ich dann
auch noch das hier entdeckt so richtig
klar dass ich sowas entdecker ins dunkel
draußen ist
im land denken gehirn in der hand oder
so ich werde ich ertrinke oh mein gott
ich dachte ich wer von ihnen
vorgeschlagen
ich weiß nicht warum ich so was immer
dann entdecke wenn es halt dunkel
draußen ist aber da waren irgendwelche
gebäude und ich weiß nicht was die haben
da ihm wie kisten drin sind oder
irgendwelche anderen sachen aber
irgendwie sieht dass hier sehr
verdächtig aus ich habe mich immer
besser kiste wir sind zwar krise
schatzkarte drin
also wir werden wieder einen schatz
finden der heutigen episode nebenfolge
horoskop was ist das hier das in sein
gehirn das ist die sau die lokale die
mir für diese liebe der für diese abitur
blogger brauchen ich plötzlich hier
vorne an land jetzt einfach mal eine
fackel dass wir überhaupt irgendeine
lichtquelle haben nehme meine
ofenkartoffeln und ist jetzt erstmal was
damit sich mein leben auch ein bisschen
auffüllt ich weiß nicht ob da unten noch
mehr ist das sind ja noch mehr von
diesen konstruktionen und ob dann
eventuell noch in die diamanten
schlummern oder so habe ich hätte jetzt
einfach mal hingehen ich meinen
probieren geht über studieren das ein
ganz bekannter spruch von mir hier ist
auch eine kiste hoffe dass da etwas
krasses drin ist jetzt eine angel mit
dem fluch des verschwindens und
verrottetes fleisch ich weiß nicht ob
wir noch mehr von diesen gebäuden sind
hier ist ein gebäude da hier voll auf
seine konstruktion es ist echt heftig
was ich von glück habe in diesem
kompletten projekt was generelle sachen
angeht was thron angeht was unter wasser
tempel jetzt hier gerade an geht jetzt
auch noch eine kiste
hier ist nur weizen drin und noch eine
schatzkarte also wir können zwei schecks
anscheinend finden schnell raus da vorne
kommt auch schon zombie ich muss auf
jeden fall ganz schnell weg hier vorne
ist flipper glaube ich er hat allerdings
nicht mehr dieses dinge beim kopf oder
war das ein anderer delfine das hatte
auch gottes sind hier vorne auch monster
ich muss einfach nur zu meinem boot
kommen das kann nicht wahr sein dass es
hier schon wieder jetzt solle chaos
folge die aua natürlichen krieger
natürlichen creeper natürlich ein krieg
ich weiß nicht mehr wo ich mein boot
geparkt habe was da hinten irgendwo ich
jetzt gerade schon mal hier bin werde
ich auf jeden fall auch ein bisschen
holz mitnehmen denn und das schaffe ich
leider nicht mehr in der heutigen folge
ich bin in der bruder teil schon bei
einer stunde 45
das muss ich gleich noch runter karten
und so weiter und so fort eigentlich
sollte heute ja auch tik tok user kommen
es tut mir leid an alle die das
eventuell heute erwartet haben
allerdings habe ich euch ja in den
plätzen video von minecraft projekt
entscheiden lassen ob ich jacob tuesday
hochladen soll oder minecraft und am
ende fast alle dass sich minecraft
hochladen soll
von daher kommen auf jeden fall nächste
woche die sache
er hat nicht flipper im kopf stehen da
vorne steht ein händler melden darf ich
auf gar keinen fall wieder angucken
die sache ist dass er hinten ja schon
unsere insel ist ich weiß allerdings
schon wieder das sei extrem viele
monster sein werden weil ich einfach
wieder fast die komplette nacht jetzt
weg war die nacht er schon mehr als die
hälfte vorbei vielleicht sind unsere
schildkröteneier geschlüpft das können
wir mal ganz kurz checken was sich
gerade sagen wollte war dass ich
eigentlich in der heutigen episode noch
ein haus bauen wollte für unseren willen
mit betten damit er sich vermehren kann
ich hab mich da ein bisschen informiert
die sache ist allerdings dass wir heute
wirklich nicht mehr zu kommen das wird
alles in der nächsten folge passieren
schildkröteneier sind auch noch nicht
gestoppt die sind ja alle noch am start
ich platziert einfach das boot mal hier
vorne gehe an land und hoffe wirklich
dass hier nirgends wo irgendwelche
monster sind wir haben ja eigentlich tui
am start der uns beschützen soll
er macht das aber irgendwie einfach
nicht und schild noten in der höhle
allerdings in das jetzt ich zeige euch
was ich mir dabei gedacht haben und zwar
könnte man hier ein seerosen dorthin
packen hier vorne dann wieder hier so
ein bisschen so einen kleinen weg der so
aussieht als wäre eigentlich normal hier
irgendwie generiert worden allerdings
auch irgendwie nicht und das geile ist
dann können wir den halt hier
weitermachen in die richtung und
irgendwann wenn wir dabei unser obsidian
nehmen und unser feuerzeug ich glaube
wir haben ja sogar schon alle
materialien die wir benötigen um in den
neckar zu gehen
allerdings will ich das auch so ein
bisschen vorher schieben dann können wir
auf jeden fall hier noch so eine kleine
insel bauen dann haben wir so einen weg
der zwar auch funktioniert aber nicht so
gekünstelt aussieht wie sondern normaler
weg jetzt irgendwie mit strengen oder so
dass hier finde ich auf jeden fall so
ein bisschen schöner abend noch ein
bisschen schöner cooler und so ein
bisschen natürlich von daher ich
sortiere meine items jetzt noch mal so
ein bisschen und wir können uns ja auch
mal eben kurz die schatzkarte hier
angucken wir haben zwar okay das ist
einfach die gleiche karte die wir jetzt
irgendwie zweimal haben das wird
allerdings alles in der nächsten folge
stattfindet meine lieben freunde dort
werde ich dann unter anderem den schatz
hier suchen und hoffentlich auch finden
ich werde ein haus für die dorfbewohner
bauen ich werde dann hoffentlich
schildkröten babys haben ja könnten
einmal ganz kurz gucken ob die gestützt
sind dagegen gar nichts voran
wenn euch das heutige video allerdings
gefallen hat dann das gerne einen daumen
hoch unter dem video hier da abonniert
main kanal falls sie jedoch keinen teil
der luke schulzeit und die nächste folge
minecraft mit luca nicht verpassen
wollte die kommen nämlich übermorgen
online am donnerstag um 20 uhr
[Musik]